I don't have enough of sleep I don't
have enough sleep although I'm getting
good you know but I just there's so much
I want to do in the day when the kids
are asleep I end up getting so excited
and so I stay up a little bit too late
doing things that I can't normally do
when the kids are awake
sharks
I just really as much as even I get in
the ocean or as much as I try to go
diving and stuff I still just in the
back of my head I just think there's
gonna be this these jaws behind me and
it's just gonna I feel like I'm getting
better at structure I've never been a
very you know really I like just to sort
of be kind of freewheeling and like okay
let's go there let's do this and then
you have two kids and then you know you
have certain men come through your life
who are like can we like get some
structure here can we just like try to
figure out what the next at least three
weeks is gonna look like so I've had to
kind of learn how to sort of reel it in
and make sure I you know
have some order well boys snuggling
every morning a really like great awful
reality television show like in bed just
with cookies biscuit
just just rain dead television you know
that's kind of always a great fun ending
to a crazy day I think having a great
strong support group of women is so
important gets you through so much to
have women supporting each other
you